el fósforo 32 es radioactivo y de hecho
tiene un decaimiento beta y de hecho ya
hemos hablado del decaimiento beta en el
vídeo anterior aquí está nuestra
partícula beta y el fósforo se va a
convertir en azufre muy bien ahora
digamos que empezamos con 4 miligramos
de fósforo 32 y digamos también que
vamos a esperar
esperamos 14.3 días muy bien esperamos
en 14.3 días y lo que observamos es
cuánto fósforo nos queda y resulta ser
que vamos a observar que hay 2
miligramos por supuesto el resto se ha
convertido ya en azufre y esa es la idea
de la vida media fijémonos en la
definición de qué es la vida media ok
nos dice la vida media es el tiempo que
le lleva a la mitad de los núcleos
radiactivos de caer es decir si
empezamos con 4 miligramos perdemos la
mitad de eso entonces nos quedamos
justamente con 2 miligramos y eso nos
llevó
14.3 días para que ocurriera en verdad
así que 14.3 días es la vida media del
fósforo 32 y este es el símbolo que
utilizamos para la vida media así que 14
punto tres días es la vida media del
fósforo 32 y la vida media depende de de
qué elementos o qué sustancias estemos
hablando verdad por ejemplo si estamos
hablando de algo como uranio 238 la vida
media es distinta es aproximadamente
4.47 por 10 a la 9 años y eso es mucho
más largo que la vida media del fósforo
32 muy bien así que vamos a quedarnos
con el fósforo 32 en este vídeo de hecho
vamos a empezar con 4 miligramos como
hemos iniciado en este vídeo sólo para
ayudarnos a entender qué es la vida
media así que ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es graficar la tasa de decaimiento del
fósforo 32 muy bien fijémonos ahora en
nuestra gráfica que tenemos aquí en el
eje y
vemos la cantidad de fósforo 32 y
digamos estamos trabajando aquí en
miligramos muy bien así que esto estará
en miligramos y en el eje x tenemos el
tiempo y esto lo estamos midiendo en
días muy bien simplemente pues porque
así estamos midiendo la vida media
verdad y esto se vuelve mucho más fácil
si lo calculamos en días muy bien así
que vamos a empezar con nuestros 4
miligramos de nuestra muestra por
supuesto eso corresponde a cuando el
tiempo es igual a 0 verdad cuando el
tiempo es igual a cero tendremos cuatro
miligramos de fósforo 32 y si nosotros
esperamos 14.3 días digamos que aquí
estamos en 14.3 días entonces tendremos
la mitad de estos 4 miligramos verdad
entonces tendremos la mitad que
justamente es 2 y podemos poner una
marca de este en este plano verdad para
ir graficando este punto entonces
después de 14.3 días tendremos 2
miligramos que es
la mitad de 4 digamos ahora que
esperamos otra vida media es decir otros
14 puntos tres días entonces tendremos
28.6 días y ahora lo que tendremos es la
mitad de lo que teníamos anteriormente
es decir la mitad de dos y eso nos da
uno muy bien entonces en 28.6 días vamos
ahora a tener un miligramo de fósforo 32
vamos a esperar
otra vida media digamos que ande por
aquí y esos son 42 puntos 9 días y ahora
tendremos la mitad de lo que teníamos
anteriormente que era 1 es decir vamos a
tener punto 5 miligramos después de 42
puntos 9 días y aquí ya tienes una idea
de dónde estarían los siguientes puntos
verdad y podríamos continuar haciendo
esto pero yo creo que con esto ya
tenemos una muy buena idea de cómo se ve
la gráfica verdad así que si pensamos en
la gráfica se ve
y así más o menos verdad
que después se hace de esta forma esta
sería como la gráfica del decaimiento
exponencial por eso es que decimos que
es un decaimiento exponencial de esto
hablamos cuando tocamos el tema de
decaimiento radioactivo ok vamos a
hablar un poquito más de esto sobre el
decaimiento exponencial en el próximo
vídeo pero al menos esto nos ayuda a
entender qué es lo que está ocurriendo
así que a medida que aumentamos el
número de vidas medias que dejamos
esperando verdad entonces podemos ver
que la cantidad de material radioactivo
disminuye verdad y esto simplemente es
es un problema relativamente sencillo
verdad si empezamos con 4 miligramos de
fósforo 32 por ejemplo podríamos
preguntarnos cuánto tendríamos después
de cierto número de días vamos a
plantear ese problema
digamos que comenzamos con 4 con 4
miligramos de fósforo 32 cuánto queda
después de 57.2 días así que vamos a
esperar esa cantidad de días y nosotros
sabemos que la vida media del fósforo 32
es
0.3 días muy bien así que cuántas vidas
medias tenemos con 57 puntos dos días
bueno tendremos 57.2 días si lo
dividimos entre 14.3 esto nos da cuatro
verdad son cuatro vidas medias las que
tenemos que digamos las que tenemos con
57 puntos dos días así que si empezamos
con cuatro miligramos una forma muy
simple de hacerlo es tenemos cuatro
miligramos y dejamos pasar una vida
media muy bien digamos que dejamos pasar
una vida media entonces tendremos la
mitad que son dos miligramos déjenme
dejar sólo el 2 luego dejamos pasar otra
me da vida media persona y ahora
tendremos la mitad de 2 que eso no
dejamos pasar otra vida media y
tendremos la mitad de uno que es 0.5 y
si dejamos pasar una cuarta vida media
tendremos 0.25 miligramos de fósforo 32
muy bien y esta es una forma de calcular
la cantidad de miligramos que tenemos
después
de estos 57 puntos dos días ahora
también podríamos haber hecho lo
siguiente digamos que tengo cuatro
miligramos verdad y a la primera vida
media hay que multiplicarla por un medio
a la segunda vida media hay que
multiplicar por un medio a la tercer
vida media hay que multiplicar por un
medio y como sólo tenemos cuatro vidas
medias perdón multiplicamos por un medio
finalmente verdad entonces esto también
lo podríamos escribir como cuatro por un
medio elevado a la 4 verdad y eso si
hacemos las cuentas tendremos 4
multiplicando a 1 sobre 16 verdad 2 a la
4 es 16 y 4 entre 16 nos da justamente
0.25 miligramos muy bien entonces esta
es otra forma de encontrar la respuesta
y en realidad no importa cómo lo hagamos
verdad de hecho siempre vamos a obtener
la misma respuesta ok también podríamos
haber hecho esto directamente de la
gráfica si es que tenemos una gráfica
muy decente por ejemplo si esperamos
otra vida media
digamos la marca de una cuarta vida
media entonces nos vamos a la gráfica y
podemos observar que el valor que toma
es digamos la cantidad de fósforo 32 se
ve en la gráfica que es más o menos la
mitad de 0.5 verdad que es 0.25
miligramos así que es otra forma de
verlo ahora bien en el próximo vídeo
vamos a hablar de cómo graficar este
decaimiento exponencial